so let me introduce Jarrett event is a
break facility department near Barcelona
and he's gonna talk about how to use
graphs of how the user claps for
security okay thank you thank you good
afternoon as posted I'm going to enter
PhD student at University of Barcelona
and this work is part of my thesis and
because I'm a discipline in sociology
it will such a sociability content so
it's by data so I hope that you find in
the AFC I will read the more
sociological part at the beginning
because we will talk about web scale
operation and quality groups and then we
will focus on the title of on the
content on the web in the title of the
talk which is analyzing the contribution
to achieve Python project using network
analysis and network X and math pathways
so let me start with operation so it is
a name of in sociology because being
analyzed and terrorized for a long time
in sociology and there are mainly two
main approaches a macro level and a
micro level approach the macro level is
the oldest one and classical sociology
like Karl Marx or Max Weber have talked
about whole groups and large
organization covers and what was and
what not so this approach being a macro
mode approach in a focus on the whole
group like the authority forms that we
should pass the trust between the people
that
or in the organization of the group and
share values involved that that these
organization has more recently biblical
approach has taking a lot of attention
in security in from this point of view
operation is called as the visual level
perineum in which individuals decide or
not understand or multisite good
coverage and this is model using usually
using agent-based model but it's really
an individual's body an approach what a
leading might be is we learned when we
will talk a here in this talk is about a
meta-level approach operation based on
on groups and groups inside organization
this with a level is interesting because
all to bridge the gap between the macro
level and the micro level approach but
you have several problems for instance
for instance the concept of group
cohesion and group itself is not
well-defined socialism so mainly it's
using the sociologically the root cause
is very young people because the
recognition and admin career and we
don't have like a quantitative value of
authorizing a group is an iterative
problem because if you change you
analyzed one group in one setting or
whether in other settings you cannot
compare policy and usually the
the definition of what a group is is
grounded in intuition and common sense
and this is not a good way to analyze
groups but in sociology there are quite
lesson we actually maybe during the
seventies of last century the social
network analysis that we're very used
approach to analyze this kind of things
and the relational component which is
based on the connection between the
people that work group allows us to
define autocatalytic matrix to assess
the business and what a group is there
are a lot of network analysis and after
a lot of measures about the groups and
other questions for instance the multi
cell majors like wix1 scoops t course
lambda set pleasure and more effectively
that means the detection algorithm the
problem with this most of these
approaches is that they don't capture of
what what sociologists prepare as a
poison pool because avoided group should
have mainly three characteristics the
first one it should be produced so it
would not that group should not depend
on the actions or not only one
individual if you look at this diagram
you can't invoke this as a group with a
charismatic video so it can be that this
group if you are will remove a
charismatic leader the group dissolves
so this is not produce i am going to
prove that if you look at this complete
graph there is no actor in the group
that can by leaving the group can
resolve between so a major of group
cohesion should be removed should also a
measure of group ahead and shoot out or
overlapping because people is not only
activated with one
inside an organization but it's more
than one rule and these are a lot of
people in different groups is very
important information especially for the
kind of things in which various studies
operation and finally it should be
hierarchical idea because we have in
many social settings we have groups that
are as museum dogs that one group is
inside another group and this
hierarchical nested of groups is one of
the feature result of collisions than we
want to analyze and preservation work
from white entirely and William white
proposed a precise definition of
cohesion or group based on a gradual
radical measure of poverty and this
recognition a group supervision equals
the minimum number of actors who is
removable will disconnect a group and a
logistic regression is equal to the new
number of not independent partly in each
pair of actors is mathematically
equivalent by the manger area which is a
very well known terror from director and
the nice thing about this concept is
that captures two of the main uses of
cohesion in the sociological literature
that means a group does not depend on
any individual so by the monkey revenue
stays the same and people if your group
is related to each other for multiple
parts so there is no actor that
centralized all the corrections and all
the flows of information in that group
so with this addition of North Pole
affinity and the relation of this is a
concept of
his own body in that theory a component
a graph is a maximal connected sub graph
which means that there is at least one
part between any actor in the in the sub
graph so eight components are subtract
retinas of that that has at least no
selectivity game which means that we
remove at least K actors is nodes who
greet to break in more a more components
or more groups and if you look at an
example here the hierarchical structure
of each paper body as you can see the
red nodes for a poor component which
means that they are group that we listen
for actors to disconnect them and this
will be a very nice purple group of
urban model that you have to remove
three of these actors who are babies
look and which is inventing the blue
nodes that form a two-component so you
see this hierarchy of groups and these
methods that actual statistical concept
are operating so I'm officially stool
analysis of the typical process of
analysis I needed a example of
large-scale operation a technology that
is well known and then use of is quite a
most popular programming languages but
the most important thing is that we have
the tail electronic records of social
contributions which means that I have
from a negative 1 to 2040
2015 I had all the records of what
people who visit to approach so and well
I gave that everyone else here the
secret of Python project is a reference
implementation of the Python programming
language it was decided in 1981 as a
personal project from a bureaucracy and
nine developers were contributing to the
source code in 1999 and 62 developers in
2014 so and with a very pretty weak and
complex project a frequency source code
files there was there were more than
1000 in 1999 and more than 2000 in 2014
so and what I did for mobile information
as a network I have use what I call
operation network which is basically a
Bible and met work in which we have
depended no one on one side we have
developers and on other side without a
source code files and then for each year
and having briefs
between developers and source code files
is that developer contributed Alec Poe
who that source code file and people
together complete electronic articles
then we can look at the evolution from
1989 until now and then it is a new
model what is important is wet one you
analyze a language in an umbilical Teddy
we have to be able to compare with some
new model to make sure that
you are observing is not the result of
pure chance so I will show you some
pictures that maybe it will be easier to
understand what I'm talking about
so this is the by cooperation Network in
1999 we imagined a d1 service with only
one developer which is this circle in
the mirror and the triangles and the
source code file
the typical interval is universal and is
linked to all the source files that she
contributed sample and at that time it
was not with you so now we pass over to
999 then here we have nine developers so
nine circles and as you can see we can
we realized the key components in these
biotech networks we see that there are
different levels like these nose here
former group that you need to remove
three notes to describe them two and one
and if we look at the evolution of his
network service and it working with a
global notes but I am avoiding the edges
and I'm working a 3d version in which
the high the z axis is the the
collectivity that we develop of you
before
so and for Fears there are some
interesting things because in 2000 many
more developers join the Python project
and as you can see here the hierarchy of
preclude 11 Scrolls a lot as growth the
number
of source code files and if we look at
the evolution you can see that more and
more developers during the project and
these are actual of computer level is my
mind and you can see that there is a
predictive hierarchy in which at the top
you can see the developers that are in a
more cohesive groups they are running
the new model it is a Pentagon and I do
not focus a lot of that work for me to
show you the range of it is that if you
assign a memory developers source code
files maintaining the constraint of
source of developer profile you tank
this structure we did not add
hierarchical as this one and this is an
indication that there is some underlying
directive memories mechanism that is not
a full changeable around so that we are
on something and oh voice is relevant so
what I found in my research is that it
look at this graph this is the
percentage of developers my core
activity level so the robots are at the
top four it is developed each year I all
40% of the total developers and
to Python or C fiber that year but if
you look at the back of the right this
is a contribution rate volatility level
and you can see that most of the years
the developers developers up at the top
of the connectivity structure actually
between ninety percent of the poll so
and this is relevant for the
sociological available and I will show
you but let me first say that B is only
a correlation so this means that people
develop that on the top of the hierarchy
ever wonder could reduce the most but I
think also additional motivated the
statistical modeling for another sort of
the Isles language both added to item
project like that by organization with
the one and year since effects I also
see was saluted particular potential
political columnist at this world I also
modeled the number of hostages pets like
hypertension country proposals wherever
the during the negative binomial and the
results are that the people at the top
of the higher your activity levels of
the operation networks cpython projects
contribute more and also cut more are in
proposals except it is relevant in the
social calendar forum on priests offer
it was this leader who made when we take
two directions the first one is to
reconcile the open source the open
source program with
follow me which in fact individuals are
all economical and if you have no
benefit you will do anything and this
stream of the desert are focusing only
mostly on individuals and what are the
motivations of people on the other hand
it has been another stream of very
important as just a theory that is a big
nice about our open source software
thinking that communities of open source
of work I propose from both by loosely
organized individuals with a very flat
or non-existent iron and the fact is
that when you look in critically at most
of free software projects and
participate in any feasible project and
so that you are very aware that bayview
people continues most of the bowl and
then these analyses of the groups of
reactivity structure of the the
patient's network of priests or world
projects if as the ability to point out
why these these developers and it is
relevant also because this factor like
that are all related to participants I
don't want to produce the most of the
poll is well known not is not very
present in sociology but especially
composes the science you beat any free
software project you will see the
contributions come from Beijing people
and this has led to some outdoors who
directed maybe something like
iron law of oligarchy is working in
software projects that organizations
tend toward a non-linearity as we grow
even if Democratic participation from
the port of Naples and any that I showed
you until now cannot support this
hypothesis it was as we see as we saw
only way to be both contribute most
people but the thing is that if you look
at doing an analysis of these networks
the people that are at the top of the
higher in each year change a lot so we
are not talking upon alliterative than
32 people is the only one that is at the
top but if you look at the because I
promise and go out from the 12th
position of hierarchies extend a lot
this timing diagram refers to the same
plus that I shown you before and that
ultimately develop for instance this
year which is 2007 so at the top of the
hierarchy at the beginning of the year
there were 12 people but that year 13
more new developers the new developers
and the top of the community strategy
and it means that the dynamic in
settlement modularity is more like an
open airy so that the you look legit
ordinary there is a lot of new block
entering the top positions of priorities
and contributing most of of the whole
instead of cpython
but as we have in other open source
projects Sankey diagram yeah but what
this has a very nice
and finally so what I also read in this
model is wearing the remoteness in terms
of the Nintendo salutes violence usually
in network enabled measure you measure
ruinous bisecting tables and attached to
the note by the window and see the size
of the giant collected fumble what I
read is a survival and which is one more
method mystical technique which analyzed
with this obscure personal as a model
and what I found is that people at the
top of the hierarchy and to say a lot
more in the project another way of
looking at this is with these survival
function so if you look at all the
developers that contributed at least one
line of source code in Python here the
block is the median survival time of a
developer in a community which is
defined as a point in time where an
average suppose the population has
abandoned the community and each six
years if you consider all the workers
together but if you look only at the
total of the current duty levels
this is twelve years instead of six and
people that is not involved is only
three years
so in conclusion and engaging with these
this method the structure of a component
nicely captures iron in the patterns of
relations of various contributors when
working for error and these attacks in
Vidigal will satisfy that in principle
projects Omega two participants
contribute most of the poll and refused
rank views that you are that piece of
rural communities have not
hierarchy and I like the usual in which
more more or less everyone was the same
so the important into social dancing was
vibration as a central invention because
because of energy in these groups has an
important political significant impact
on the bone on the volume of video
contributions and on the very active
life of developers and I show you that
this monetary structure is not a reality
that is the same time but is more like
an ordinary where people are enter and
enter at a higher value so and this
helps to understanding the mechanism and
I learned that our free software
projects where people that participate
doesn't get their means of subsea of
subsist subsistence from the water they
do in the project but these are to
nowhere and this renewal of individuals
is what else who are achieved items I
can boil results as a result of
large-scale operation and it is all your
wife you can watch this live action here
and here put some other currencies if
you have any question
[Applause]
well we have three minutes okay
hello thank you very much for your talk
totally blew my mind I definitely want
to know what I have a question about the
plus that universal yes the first one
what does the X and one-dimensional
mythical - Janine strength yet require
the X&Y dimensions are the result of a
canal acquire layout algorithm so I can
like a wild album from track positions
notes in the two dimensions based on
analogy on a physical system based on a
comparator and is what you usually use
to plot in two dimensions or the nodes
of a network and then this layer of
algorithm to put together note that more
closely related and then leaving the X&Y
be Nations which puts more or less the
notes more length in your controller and
then the Z dimension of ethical
dimension is this connectivity Network
okay and the other one when you're
putting the graph of the people entering
and leaving the community did you
consider people that might leave at some
point and then enter again very low
point
so I actually considered consider this
but I was not able to work piece in
Shangai be a gap because then I had a
lot of crossovers at the top so I have a
table that they are removed from the
slide but frequently and and this is a
very important feature so when you have
been at some point in time at the
profitable TV level the probabilities
that you get back that for some reason
you contribute less the next few years
but after two or three years you
contribute a lot and then you get
at the probability level ISA are quite
high and these are also of interesting
accuracy and I will be if you are
dressing my TV is in this up to your
same repository we just had a lot more
probably more than you want to know this
for sure okay so yeah it was super
interesting I I have two questions with
that yeah one how easy will be to throw
a random project stored on github and
run your analysis on it and get this
kind of that would be I mean if you were
to produce a tool such as that that
would be super helpful for a lot of open
source projects well I actually am
working on this so anonymity is like in
two weeks so I'm focus on that I am the
next future important piece that we know
because this is like so in my thesis I
analyze and get the C Python process and
the Debian project and the next step is
to pick a big sample of open source
projects at Zipcar and then see if there
is a drain because it is only this is
not an empirical test is only that these
words like this in Debian I mean C
Python and the next step is to pick a
big tangle and one of the plans is to
put together and it's not very difficult
so this is implemented in network X so
I'm going to do I am a part of the
developer team of Network X and I
contributed all that I am is like the
key components and all connectivity
everything is in network X so it will be
you can right now yourself topeka
ajeeb repositories and to create a
network extract and compute this measure
because the between network pet but I
didn't really plan to put something in
this hat too easily
[Music]
great great thank you and another
question and this is another one of
those not really equesticle that's
Google at work so it's very organization
ok so your your talk sort of gives the
old you know there's some thinking out
there that open-source projects tend to
be really very valid article and there's
like this group at the top that's
holding on to it and only people give in
and they're all white dudes and and and
this is sort of like the reassurance oh
no no we're not like that right there
are nice people comes in and goes I
wonder if there is and and the question
about people we enter in and going out
maybe give such a tone that things are
not as apparent as your as what we were
I mean it's just this thinking that your
methods can be used to deny that there
are problems in open-source projects do
you have any thoughts on that well quite
particular and the other interesting
remark because I would say that if we
are able to look at the individual
attributes of people I will say that the
mostly era
white guys between 20 and 50 and maybe
one of the ideas also occasionally with
me is that if you want to improve the
value of
what you have to do is socialize the
knowledge so I think that the icon
project has a routine that Allah has
favored documentation and the gold and
is that is quite accessible so it's
relatively easy to dive on that but I
think that what open source projects
should do is a symptom of these
explicitly and put mechanisms and tools
for people to enter like to understand
the visionaries that this body and work
on mentoring people being able to enter
at the top and contribute a lot of
horror stories
thank you follow-up question you confer
or did you compare with any other a
naturalistic any other kind of social
group that need to cooperate different
completely different medicine - Luce
with a typical lateral pattern or
something more artificial or really
specifically available points of my
senses focus on open source communities
and also on scientific operation we are
also shipping papers and we see a more
or less religious similar trend there
but the thing is that in open source
everything is very fast erratic renewal
is very fast in scientific communities
that gradually slow so my intuition and
this is something like at a future war
that this kind of analysis are could be
applied to many other interesting
subsistence and Winston I mean I will be
when directed to compare open-source
tools we like compile internal company
processes that develop software to
compare each economic company that
develops software we see some pattern
like this or not but so far the problem
with easy that there is no available
energy like we say most 5000
and compare it with another artist in
ways maybe in group of animals or so
okay whether this may be that is an
optimal solution for daily co-creation
problem a maybe this is reflected also
in nature in group of animals and type
of profitability Paris but I'm not aware
of any well in general from the security
perspective you I would say that this
reality is very different because the
probation as so there are a lot of
output in sociology that would tell you
that the underlying mechanisms are
different so the operation of the human
level and especially knowledge vital
based protein process like wiping papers
or building software you need conscious
toleration of people and you get a
coordination problem generation
mechanism another level I can't solve
anything
oh well like with pheromones dead and
the underlying mechanisms are different
and ago sociology I can't agree as
solely between I tend to agree with this
and I would say that at the natural
level we would apply these analogies but
the underlying energy would be different
essential in capital cases of Allen as a
fellow busy student and happier we are
getting here too it's kind of personal
so I was wondering during your there
question round if you say that you have
unrelated
preference for eat mothers whose
relatives having a role in this is their
agenda name another project or world man
you see at a spike in collaboration or
more dynamical contributions and entry
and exit of the university well this is
not part of my thesis but I'm here I
would remember where but I see like
applaud in which many of the sci-fi for
packages I might probably to buy a
desert with a lot of contributions and
when they move to jihad and the thing
when exponential so I'm sure that this
happens kind of wet Oh sweetie ha ha ha
with the with the they agree so for
participation in many open-source
projects in the case of cpython
it is from 91 to 2014 and English which
is have like New Belgium moons ago so I
don't think the case in a survival but I
would guess that if we pick like a
project maybe not oh bleep or network X
also make something like this we would
ship in spiked when they need to discuss
so just briefly now here it is a wide
range of the ability type of human
networks omega2 it as a relative of
disciplines that like the private sector
and specifically to study organic
private sector groups dynamics and to
provide metrics of our own orientations
working action there is very little data
on that because this is something that
private organizations consider like an
industry sector and there are not a lot
but what in the situation elevator there
is what is called internal organic
intra-organizational Network which is
not a technical kind of analogy into the
provision model for some problems and
some dynamics in the situation community
has not been values and I hope that in
the future especially now that we have
more computational tools to perform this
kind of analysis we will see more but
you know there are analogies of internal
workings of pilot central organization
but they are very few
for this reason because it is very
difficult to access the data organs can
we put in traditional
intra-organizational networks and in
sociology and management literature so
if you go through a conditional science
through power something like this it is
a big commute and they have a pretty
good you will be able to find quite a
few papers that maybe they do not like
this exact technique of the system
out-of-work happy run okay Thank You
Georgie for $19
I'll get to health care then ultimately
I actually get a contribution because it
makes a difference if you adjust
correcting about bugs in different pies
or if you are working just one model but
no like bragging everything on the
scratch so you should see something else
yes yes good question and we dislike
monocle utilities analogies because one
go division is an issue of at least one
line code if that might not hold is like
Angel part of the project
oh it's just simple back there is no
differentiation so here I'm assuming
that the volume of contribution because
those networks are wasted by the total
number of source code lines contributed
to that soul and my only proxy or
composition is the quantity of the
contribution and this is a shortcoming
yes music as you have shown yet pause
then let's talk with you I will be there
see this will be the person so sorry for
the expression and engineers I always
think about applications when I need
mailings and you have over I object so
only if you have in the idea to how can
you use these or I always think of the
circle application so if you know the
center they click exactly know how to
attack but then you can we know what
what you can do based on this data to
improve so the name of applications are
value was indeed one more related to a
question before
like oh can we in the open-source
communities post there more
participation of more diverse people in
school as actually knowing who is at the
top you know who to attack or maybe to
hire in the North exactly in your
company that would be but my thinking on
liability of my divisions I have in mind
is to improve the open-source community
in which we participate with is I'm a
member of this vortex and would be
interested and sometimes spending time
mentoring people like attending
reviewing other food waste and making
comics is a way to move people welcome
to know that their contributions to a
project is something that people that
smash in the present it so it's
important for them for the people and
maybe putting more people at the top and
illuminants into this mode okay but
let's thank you
[Applause]